я німкеня і більшість сприймає мене як
пунктуальну людину зрештою
пунктуальність вважається німецькою
чеснотою Але чесно кажучи це не завжди
про мене тому сьогодні я хочу дізнатися
чи справді німці такі пунктуальні якими
їх вважають Зачекай я теж тут твоя
внутрішня німкеня твоє маленьке німецьке
сумління І я можу тебе запевнити що я
завжди пунктуальна Ну якщо ти так кажеш
гляньмо наскільки німці пунктуальні у
вільний час у громадському житті та на
роботі звучить Добре я доведу тобі що ми
завжди
[музика]
пунктуальні німці та робота Ось що
одразу асоціюється з пунктуальністю та
ефективністю зазирнімо в офіс аби
перевірити чи це правда але це надто
впритул чому ж мені потрібно лише 15
хвилин щоб дістатися до роботи а моя
зустріч у мій а якщо трамвай спізниться
ти ж запізнишся твоя шефиня очікує Що ти
ти будеш вчасно Гаразд Можливо ти маєш
рацію Я
поспішу тепер я прийшла надто рано ти не
можеш з'явитися на зустріч настільки
рано адже 5 хвилин зарано пунктуальність
німця Ти ж знаєш це німецьке прислів'я
х Тоді я піду ще за
кавою до завтра
звісно
гей стоп зараз 5та вечора час іти додому
але я ще мушу це завершити але вже
кінець робочого дня геть звідси ти
думаєш звичайно Ми німці пунктуальні
навіть коли йдеться про кінець робочого
дня ми найменше у світі працюємо
понаднормово адже працюємо ефективно та
починаємо і закінчуємо пунктуально так
ми працюємо дедалі менше понаднормово
Але пунктуальні та ефективні ми ми не
завжди Я мушу це закінчити але обіцяю що
піду через 15 хвилин Гаразд
домовилися звичайний робочий день можна
з упевненістю сказати що німці цінують
пунктуальність на
роботі А як що до вільного часу
Ходімо Я зустрічаюся зі своєю подругою
Лізою
[музика]
Ми вчасно звісно я не хочу змушувати її
чекати Де ж вона вона чно Зараз прийде
Не
переживай перевір телефон вона щось
[музика]
написала Ні дивно як нечемно вона марнує
наш час згідно з опитуваннями більшість
німців очікують що ви прийдете
пунктуально або зі спізнення максимально
на 5 хвилин вибач за спізнення мій
телефон розрядився інакше б я б
неодмінно попередила без проблем німці
люблять коли вибачаються за спізнення
тоді все швидко
забувається Я теж треба буде незабаром
знову на каву зустрітися чао-чао а як що
до вечірок коли приходять пунктуальні
німці з цим усе трохи складніше тут
пунктуальність залежить від контексту
вечірки і хто взагалі приходить на
вечірку
пунктуально ми і ми маємо ще щось
принести із собою тому поспішай
[музика]
Ходімо
Ой що ти тут робиш хіба вечірка не о
8мій вечора з 8ї
вечора коротке тлумачення з 20ї не
означає бути пунктуальним але контекст
важливий чим менша вечірка тим більше
очікування що гості зберуться більш-менш
пунктуально А якщо вас запросили на
вечерю то приходити слід справді вчасно
Гаразд тоді запитай чи можеш ти їй
чимось допомогти о вибач можу я тобі
чимо
Так звісно
[музика]
хух далеко не все так просто з німецькою
пунктуальністю німці дуже пунктуальні на
роботі але в особистому житті все не так
строго залишається ще з'ясувати
наскільки пунктуальне громадське життя в
Німеччині приміром
[музика]
транспорт дивно що потяга досі нема чи
не так зовсім не дивно але ж це нетипово
для Німеччини відправи 16 сьогодні
приблизно на 10 хвилин пізніше 10 хвилин
неймовірно Чесно кажучи таке трапляється
постійно Розслабся німецькі потяги
доволі ненадійні Ми на 19-му місці з 27
країн ЄС здивована ганьба адже ми
запізнимося на
зустріч Не хвилюйся я це врахувала ми ще
встигаємо потім запізся на
3 А тепер що ж реальність схоже не
зовсім відповідає
хоча ми любимо
пунктуальність абсолютно пунктуальність
є цінним надбанням у Німеччині це
історично закріплено в німецькій
культурі а наскільки пунктуальні ви
пишіть нам у коментарях на
YouTube